how's it going bros my name is Pippa so
today's society puts on a huge pressure
on women to wear makeup and constantly
and I just look at I just look at it and
I'm like they look so much better
without makeup so what we're gonna do
here today is we're gonna take
supermodels and we're going to Photoshop
so we can see them without makeup and
that way prove that they are more
beautiful without makeup because they're
truly are I know this is a little bit
serious video but I feel like it's an
important message and I I think we
should do it so let's go so we got Cara
Delevingne in it and let's let's let's
start with her super famous supermodel
here's a picture where you can really
see the makeup so let's start off by
removing the lipstick so yeah I it looks
so much better I don't understand why
all right let's focus on the left eye
okay it looks like she has a little bit
of cross eye but that's that's fine
that's charming see what we can do about
her famous eyebrows
[Music]
it's weird well I guess with makeup you
can cover up anything really see her
about the mouth
[Music]
okay this is getting ridiculous before
makeup laughs I really you know each
mentoring them but I really think she's
way hotter without makeup if you ask me
I obviously forgot to take away the
Rouge
now she's truly without makeup okay so
there we go um I think it's really brave
of her and I think it's really good
see it's not it's not just women it's
also men let's see this picture
untouched
okay surely surely there's no flaws with
pota pie all right let's look at this oh
okay it looks like I I actually had both
eyes open in this pic oh okay
now that's sad that's interesting I must
be edited in this in this cameras oh
okay my nose is actually there that's
that's good too man my my mouth is a
little wider that's also good to know
very very interesting to know what about
my hair that my hair looks way too good
to be all I knew it I knew it my hair is
actually in an extinct weird dino
chicken Dunn's so I knew it I knew it
see society puts this pressure on me and
I have to cover up every day I don't
it's not cool man
[Music]
okay so here we have a unclearly
untouched photo of Miley Cyrus but but
with future technology that we now have
in our hands we can double untouched a
picture this has never been done before
so I am a little nervous but I do have
faith that somehow this can work out so
let's let's give it a go
[Music]
and there you have it it's quite
shocking isn't it
uh III still like she's better without
makeup clearly and it's just upsetting
so if you take a look at this super
model clearly posing with the horse
there's an error right there look at
this they clearly retouch this photo cuz
[ __ ] doesn't just fail like that alright
let's see what's truly behind the
retouching see she's a lot paler oh it's
like we found something
Oh
[Music]
see I still stand by what I said before
she's way more beautiful without makeup
clearly this is clearly Photoshop you
can so clearly see softly trying to
remove the makeup oh my god no
at all
yeah Jim it
dr. fail what the [ __ ] are you doing
there
not gonna lie have some pretty nice legs
okay so that was it for this video if
you if you enjoyed please go ahead and
wait a minute
can we scan this picture please oh god
Oh God potato people are real damnit
potato people they're everywhere even
potato people have to wear makeup it's
terrible
disgusting you see this potato just look
they look nothing alike
am i right we'll look closer closer
closer
is it starting to make sense yet